[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt torres ringe schoss habe ich
schon mal gemacht aus einem kanal
aber ist das gefühl schon ein halbes
jahrhundert her obwohl ich erst 29 das
musste ich gesagt ja es sind frittierte
normalerweise lange gepäckstücke die auf
den zucker gewälzt werden und die dann
mit einer show soße serviert werden soll
wie es auch damals gemacht heute möchte
ich schoss ringe machen und zwei
verschiedene soßen dazu zubereiten und
zwar einmal eine soundkarte source also
eine franziska mense bleibe doch beim
deutschen und eine schokoladen chilisoße
ich mache heute helle und dunkle ringe
und später gucken einfach was uns besser
schmeckt oder ob weiter gleichauf sind
ich werde jetzt zuerst mal beides saucen
herstellen denn die chance an sich sind
wirklich super schnell gemacht die
verstehen aus einem landtag
und ich will die einfach später war's
oder soße essen also frage ich mal an
mit der karamellsoße für die
karamellsoße brauche ich 200 gramm
zucker 40 gramm wasser 80 gramm butter
200 gramm sahne etwas vanille extrakt
und einen halben teelöffel meersalz
es gebe es zuerst mal den zucker in den
topf da das wasser dazu ok nimmt etwas
mehr wasser doppelt so viel wasser dass
war bisschen manager
ich habe nämlich nur grob geschätzt okay
wir sind mehr wasser damit einfach der
zucker schön bedeckt ist und jetzt
braucht ihr auch erst einmal gar keine
löffel sondern ich schaue jetzt den herd
auf hohe stufe damit der zucker
aufkochen soll es karamellisieren jetzt
am besten gar nicht rühren damit der
zucker nicht so kristallisiert also
wirklich nicht rühren einfach nur
aufkochen lassen und sobald es kocht
schalte ich du denn herz also das
kochfeld auf etwa mittel hoher hitze
zurück damit dann eben nicht so schnell
verbrennt also dann wirklich auf mittel
hoher hitze etwa bernsteinfarben
einkochen lassen und ihr müsst wirklich
jetzt auch die ganze zeit dabei bleiben
denn das karamell soll nicht verbrennen
sonst wird nämlich bitter
[Musik]
mit ein bisschen mehr wasser dauert
natürlich etwas länger aber besser als
wenn der zucker unten schon an brennt
und jetzt könnt ihr schaut mal seht ihr
hier am rand dass da noch
zuckerkristalle sind die könnt ihr mit
so einer bürste oder mit einem pinsel
mit waffe einfach so ein bisschen runter
waschen
hier am rand muss nicht aber dann habt
ihr am ende eben auch keine
zuckerkristalle mehr drin
[Musik]
jetzt geht es um sekunden
jetzt ist die farbe gut also so ein
bisschen werden stein ist schon wieder
dunkler als eben karamellbonbons denn
jetzt kaum vertrauen sahne dazu also
jetzt vom herd runter 10
ich würde zuerst die butter ein ganz
vorsichtig sein denn karamell ist
wirklich super heiß kann auch spritzen
mit schaumstoff verbrannt ich habe mit
filmen dans programm
[Applaus]
das riecht lecker sobald sich die
protagonist hat kommt die sahne da zog
die sahne ist übrigens ein bisschen
lauwarm
ich hab's nie auf zimmertemperatur das
heißt ich musste sie kurz erwärmen und
das auch ganz gut die butter am besten
auch nicht kühlschrank kalt verwenden
jetzt die sahne dazugeben schön rühren
[Musik]
und wenn sich jetzt ein klotz bildete
das nicht schlimm
dann geht einfach noch mal ganz kurz auf
dem herd kann jetzt keiner gebildet aber
ich gehe trotzdem nur mal kurz auf dem
herzen erwärmen gibt dann noch vanille
extrakt dazu und wenn ihr möchtet wie
gesagt noch mehr salz dann hab da eine
saftige karamellsoße alles sauber
sauberer wird es nicht
ok
bin ich schon drin
ich habe damit nichts zu tun ich habe
einmal kurz kochen lassen und fertig ich
gebe es jedoch salz dazu für ein salz
karamell und dann fühle ich jetzt in ein
schraubglas und dass diese einfach
abkühlen frau anfing käse aus holland
mit frau antje
muss man nicht verstehen 8 8 und dennis
wollen bitte vom kinderland abgeholt
werden
morath und es biete die eltern von murat
und dennis mögen sie bitte im kinderland
abholen danke ich gehe nicht weg
[Musik]
geschmack braucht kein profi
das jetzt ernsthaft alle werbesprüche
gemeinderat diese lasse ich jetzt
abkühlen und dann geht es direkt an die
zweite soße und ich kümmere mich nur um
die zwei eigens für die show coße
nämlich 150 gramm sahne 150 bis 200 grad
bitterschokolade der fast chilli es gibt
hier einfach beide flüssigkeiten in
einen topf und laster aufkochen
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die soße auch
gerne noch mit etwas rum verfeinern
also auch einfach hier dazugeben und
kurz aufkochen lassen
die tapete schokolade da nehme ich
einfach immer herrin schokolade weil die
einfach einen 60-prozentigen kakaoanteil
hat und die breche ich dann vorher
einfach ein stück das passt sehr gut
also immer wenn ich sage dass schokolade
sage meine ich eigentlich herren
schokolade aber ihr könnt auch
unternehmen die hat ein bisschen weniger
kakaoanteil schmeckt halt so ein
bisschen der schokolade schon sehr gut
ja und was ich immer mache es aus
kreisen
krug wie viel da noch drin war
[Musik]
jetzt kocht sie milch und die sahne
jetzt kochen die milch und die sahne
habe ich den herd ausgemacht gehöre die
schokolade ein jetzt einfach ganz kurz
warten und dann durch röhren ist sie
geschmolzen ist und wenn ihr möchtet
gebt ihr dann noch chiliflocken dazu
oder etwas suchen wenn ihr nicht möchte
dann machst du es einfach so
[Musik]
die finde ich jetzt auch ab und lasst
sie abkühlen und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal den helm brandtag
machen für die shows ringe für den brand
tag nämlich 60 gramm butter 250 gramm
wasser 200 gramm mehl eine prise salz
etwas wandel extrakt und vier bis fünf
eier
das mache jetzt die hellen schon dass
zuerst das gebe ich einfach das wasser
in den topf dann die butter dazu die
zubereitung ist aber gleich und bei den
dunklen schock so roß da nehme ich
einfach noch ein bisschen cacau dazu
also ein bisschen weniger mehl und
kakaopulver dazu die zubereitung ist da
aber gleich das heißt ihr lasst jetzt
zuerst mal das wasser mit der butter
aufkochen
salz kann auch gerne schon dazu und kurz
so lange kochen bis die butter
geschmolzen ist
so dass kocht jetzt hier schon schön die
butter ist aufgelöst jetzt kommt das
mehl dazu in einem schwung und jetzt
schön einem teig los bilden
[Musik]
jetzt einfach ein bisschen abbrennen
also nicht anbrennen das muss ich leider
hier dass man dazu sagen abbrennen
bis sich unten am boden und belag bindet
das dauerte etwa eine minute und dann
hat der teig wirklich auch die perfekte
konsistenz und kann später die gase den
backofen gebildet werden auch halten
wenn ich im backofen in der fritteuse
und dann geht der teig eben dadurch auf
also da müsste wirklich darauf achten
dass schönes abbrennen aber im backofen
es das gleiche prinzip
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt aus und am
topfboden wie gesagt der weiße belag ich
nehme jetzt den teig drauf gefüllten
jetzt um in eine schüssel und den topf
lass dir jetzt einfach abkühlen denn der
belag hier unten
er löst sich von ganz alleine jörg stiel
und sagt knupfer droht das ist unser
plus verbot um sagt frühstück wird genau
jetzt lasse ich den teig einfach ganz
kurz abkühlen stück denen dann hier
einfach ein bisschen an den rand das
aufschlag ist jetzt eine schnelle und
genau das gleiche mache ich auch hier
mit dem dunklen teig dann nehme ich
jetzt einfach 40 gramm weniger mehl und
dafür 40 gramm packung
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig abgekühlt und ich
versuche das jetzt hier mit der
küchenmaschine
ihr könnt aber auch einfach mit dem
löffel weiter rühren dauert ein bisschen
länger oder mit dem handrührgerät mit
dem knethaken jetzt kommt hier ein ein
nach dem anderen dazu ihr könnt
normalerweise auch hier aufschlagen und
rein plumpsen lassen aber bayern muss
ich sagen ich mag ich die schlag ich
gern separat auf dann sehe ich auch ob
neuer schon drin ist oder ob man
schlechtes dabei ist daher lieber so und
jetzt also zu geben beim ersten denkt
man es hört sich nicht gut aber hab da
ein bisschen geduld wenn das komplett
eingehüllt ist kommt es nächste dazu und
je nach größe der eier sind vier bis
fünf nicht zu viele nehmen zeigt dass es
auch nichts wissen sein und nicht zu
weich sein
brandt steig ist er ein bisschen fest
aber glänzend und natürlich kommt hier
noch wann elevation sie kann nicht
gleich dazu geben
so ist die konsistenz perfekt der teig
glänzt schön ist aber auch nicht flüssig
noch schön fest perfekt und jetzt
bereite ich noch den schoko teig fertig
zu und dann ist beides bereit summen auf
spritzen und frittieren und bei der show
variante tonkabohne könnt ihr entweder
dazu haben oder einfach meine tochter
passte verwenden
[Musik]
ich habe das erst mal mit dem hellen tag
der komplett in einen spritzbeutel rein
da habe ich jetzt so eine mittelgroße
seien gezackte spritztour und habe jetzt
zwei spritzbeutel der eine da ist schon
benutzt und dann nehme ich auch immer
ganz gern zwei übereinander
die sind zwar stabil aber brandtag ist
wirklich da muss man sehr mit druck
arbeiten und da nehme ich einfach zwei
um sicherzustellen dass wirklich nichts
platzt und die könnte dann einfach
auswaschen und das nächste mal wieder
benutzen hat man einfach so ein besseres
gefühl dann in der hand auch wenn ihr
die toros als lange strenge macht könnt
ihr sie jetzt im prinzip direkt dann
gleich ins halte verein stritten und
dann immer mit einer schere abschneiden
ich mache das aber trotz bringe also
muss ich dir jetzt vorher auf spritzen
und habe hier mit backpapier das wird
gleich zugeschnitten aber ich mache
jetzt erstmal alle ringe damit ich das
backpapier nicht halten muss
und jetzt hier oben also beim
spritzbeutel ist wirklich wichtig oben
zu drehen
die hand hebt den druck aus und die hand
führt also die hand hier worden
ob jetzt links oder rechtshänder sein
ist egal hauptsache die hand hier oben
hält einfach den spritzbeutel fest und
drückt und die hand unten führt und
jetzt einfach kleine ringe auf spritzen
[Musik]
jetzt schneide ich das backpapier
einfach auseinander
ich habe jetzt auch noch nicht den
ganzen tag gemacht und mache ich jetzt
gleich aber ich möchte jetzt nicht die
ganze backpapier rolle verschwenden
daher benutze ich jetzt hier das
backpapier das rät ihr schon mal neben
das papier aus und benutze das
backpapier dann einfach weiter dann
braucht ihr nicht so viele zu schneiden
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sallys
frittenbude jetzt wird frittiert ihr
könnt entweder eine friteuse nehmen oder
einfach einen topf frittieren
ich würde jetzt im topf habe bereits
sonnenblumenöl oder frittierfett können
wir auch nehmen
in einem topf erwärmt auf 170 grad wenn
ihr euch nicht ganz sicher seid mit der
temperaturen in der friteuse oder
schaltet den herd auf mittel hohe stufe
ich habe jetzt ganz einfach gemacht ich
habe nämlich einfach den perfekt cook
sensor dran und kann hier genau sehen
150 grad
jetzt hält das kochfeld auch wirklich
die temperatur die ganze zeit denn wenn
ihr etwas kaltes reinkommt also so ein
ring dann heißt es wieder hoch und hält
einfach temperatur konstant
jetzt wird es hier schön reingelegt ganz
vorsichtig und mit einem holzstäbchen
könnt ihr auch das frittierfett testen
sie es jetzt auch gleich ab kann es
weiter benutzen und dann wird von beiden
seiten frittierten ausgebacken und beim
frittieren immer darauf achten nicht so
viele ringe auf einmal hinein geben
damit das fett nicht so schnell abkühlt
sonst kann es nämlich auch schäumen als
ist echt auch gefährlich das wie wenn
man in ein liter ford er fährt so drei
kilo tiefkühl pommes gibt das gedauert
und dann auspacken und rausnehmen und
danach wählt sich sie direkt in zucker
[Musik]
die
hier kann ich jetzt schon an zimt zucker
machen also einfach weißen zucker mit
zimt vermischen und ich mache das jetzt
hier in so einer schale
das riecht lecker und wenn die chorus
ringe fertig sind sie fertig aus nehme
ich sie kurz raus und lassen sie hier
abtropfen und dann kommen sie aber noch
ganz warm hier in den sinn zucker werden
darin gewälzt und sind dann erst mal
fertig
[Musik]
weg
die chorus ringe werden übrigens am
allerschönsten wenn ihr sie ins heiße
fett gibt wird sind sehr mit der
unterseiten runden
ich drehe jetzt einmal um damit erst die
unterseite gebacken wird und danach dem
umdrehen die oberseite ja so gefallen
sind wir optisch am besten und nicht so
früh raus nehmen
ich habe die ersten echt zu früh raus
genommen diesen wieder zusammen gemacht
weil ich unbedingt in seinem zucker
wenden wollte aber die nächsten die sind
perfekt diesen perfekt durch gebacken
so kann's weitergehen
[Musik]
die
die jobs sind jetzt fertig die beiden so
es nach jetzt kann probiert werden
so schnell ist keine irgendwo es regiert
das beliebte die schnellste maus von
mexiko
ich finde das schon immer wenn das ich
als mexikaner habe ich euch sagen
eigentlich war ich gerade waldarbeiten
im garten und dann haben sie gesagt denn
es soll es anziehen weil du es machst
aus mexiko
das ist ein spanisches gebäck ein von
der iberischen halbinsel und das ist
spanien portugal sollte dann gesagt das
ist mexikanisch ganz cool aussieht
ok ich möchte mich hiermit bei allen
mexikanern entschuldigen
ich möchte niemand angeblichen ja die
haben wir die gleiche sprache ja also es
gibt kein mexikanisch mexikanische
spanisch sowie amerikanisch auch
englisch ist so wusste die richtig sag's
euch solche probiert warum muss ich noch
eine schlechte nachricht für dich ja die
wäre fast schon lange vorbei kann einmal
auch du kannst es nicht mehr abgeben
weil zwei wochen rückgabe ist schon
vorbei
sie lassen immer als wild wie gehabt
nach diesen run der kreis zurückschicken
so realistisch wie begrüßen
dennis wie das ist das sag ich dir ein
okay also wir haben zum einen schock
karton pathos und sollte das kernel und
hannah vanille schoko und vanille schoko
chili anderen probieren
ich finde es ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht
berühmt ist
ich finde auch ohne dip genial
u
es hat somit die erste nation zu süß
sind der mexikaner der weiß nicht was
gut ist aber süß ich bin's ich bin
gerade die kamera ist ein bescheid aus
nämlich das erste dann macht das ganze
gesicht macht es viel spaß mit dem
chorus mit tom kawara und mit zimt und
mini sowie die in schokolade getrennt
dreimal aber auch fragen die meisten
leute immer frisch essen schmeckt am
besten muss man jetzt wieder fallen auch
gebäck immer frisch frisiert ist immer
frisch essen wenn am nächsten tag ist es
nicht mehr frittiert und frisches
nämlich mit einer mexikanischen freund
der an den denn es soll den ist kannst
du jazz bietet das griechische kostüm
für mich an zehnte kein griechisches
kopfüber und ganz sicherheit nicht wie
so was sollte die alten römer nur so ein
blatt nein nicht mein gott ich gehe
netflix markus 4 mit es ganz in rot
geworden
[Musik]
doch